The normal understanding is that you trust
a theory — the only reason to trust a theory
is that the theory has been confirmed empirically,
which means that the theory makes predictions
and those predictions then turn out to be
in agreement with empirical data. This means
that any theory that hasn’t found empirical
confirmation must be considered a pure speculation.
And this seems to be not quite right. There
are theories that haven’t found empirical
confirmation but which are trusted quite a
lot by physicists — for example, string
theory. String theory hasn’t found any empirical
confirmation but many string theorists think
they have very good reasons for trusting the
theory. And I want to understand this based
on the concept of what I call non-empirical
confirmation. The idea is that there are observations
about the context of scientific inquiry, about
the development of a theory and so on, and
those observations can generate trust in the
theory.